today's episode is brought to you by
curiositystream an incredible and
Incredibly affordable place to watch
thousands of non-fiction movies and
shows more on them in a bit
it sounds like a textbook case of
dramatic irony further proof that God
may not play dice with the universe but
he does point and laugh at us like
Nelson Muntz from the earlier stage
Benjamin Harrison believed he was
destined for great things to be not just
somebody but the somebody all other
somebody's envied when he was elected
president in 1888 he must have felt like
this was coming true that it'd become
the focal point of the universe and now
for the ironic from God because while
Harrison may have made it to the top
that's not how history remembers him
voted out after just one term Harrison
today is a model of obscurity historians
usually rank in 30th or Worse on their
list of presidential greatness in 2012
magazine even named him only half
jokingly the most forgotten president of
all time yet does Benjamin Harrison
really deserve this dire non-reputation
today biograph is he still be into the
life of the 23rd president and arguing
that there was more to Harrison than
meets the eye
when covering 19th century presidents we
often start with a hard-scramble
backstory the crazy obstacles they had
to overcome Grover Cleveland's dad was
dying for example leaving him struggling
to support the family or William
McKinley was going to fight in the Civil
War while still a teenager but not
Benjamin Harrison oh no born on the 20th
of August 1833 in Ohio the future 23rd
president arrived in a world that was
positively gilded with greatness his
father John Scott Harrison was a
prosperous farmer who would later serve
in the House of Representatives his
great-grandfather Colonel Benjamin
Harrison had been one of the signatories
to the Declaration of Independence yet
it was his grandpa who represented the
family's High Point William Henry
Harrison was the ninth president of the
United States elected in 1840 when
Benjamin was still a boy they were close
too although he'd grown up doing all of
the usual Farm Boy things Hunting
Fishing probably cow tipping Benjamin
was also fond of trotting over to
Grandpa's estate and losing himself for
hours in the older man's ass Library
when William Henry won the White House
it felt like like a natural progression
another step upwards for an emerging
American Dynasty but as you probably
remember from the Animaniacs president's
song that great step wounds up being
more like the briefest tiptoe and that's
because William Henry Harrison died
after a mere 30 days in office even with
his Grandpa's abrupt death though
Benjamin seems to have kept his sense of
Destiny his sense that his family would
return to the top for all his dad might
try to talk him out of Politics the boy
became convinced that he would one day
do something so great it would
overshadow even president grandpappy
sadly this conviction would leave an
unpleasant stain on his soul as he
became a fully grown man well relatively
he topped out at 5-6 earning himself the
nickname little Ben Harrison developed a
personality you might politely call
difficult if you were being impolite
you'd say he was arrogant and dry with a
manner so cold it was practically
Antarctic his nickname the human Iceberg
should give you some idea how his
contemporary saw him and just listened
to the only two vices he he ever
indulged in smoking cigars and eating
cucumbers yes if presidential history
were a high school movie Benjamin
Harrison would definitely be the nerd
getting pansed by jocks like Andrew
Jackson but while Harrison may have
found it difficult to make friends on a
personal level his personality deficits
tended to vanish before a crowd while
Two Minutes Alone Together would be
enough to make you hate him if he were
in a crowd or jury he was speaking to
you'd go away ready to follow him into
hell nor was it solely down to his
onstage Charisma Harrison were damn hard
all his life mastering his brief at the
expense of sleep and a family life
there's a revealing story from 1857
after he moved to Indiana and became
Indianapolis as City attorney faced with
a poisoning case he needed to prosecute
the next day Harrison zipped over to a
doctor's house and borrowed all the
books he could find on the effects of
poison he then stayed up all night
reading before walking into court the
next day and proceeding to wow everyone
with his knowledge on the subject
perhaps it's no surprise his local
Republican party was soon encouraging
him to run for state supreme court
reporter a post Harrison 1 in 1860. yet
the joy of winning will be short-lived
because in 1860 a hurricane was poised
to sweep through America a storm of
blood and iron that would upend the
lives of everyone from the lowliest
slave to the brightest star of a
political Dynasty we're talking of
course about Civil War
on the night of May 13 1864 Colonel
Benjamin Harrison sat in his tent
composing what he thought might be his
last ever letter just days earlier his
regiment to joined the army at the
Cumberland under the legendary General
William T Sherman now they were taking
part in the Atlanta Campaign The fabled
Assault on the confederacy's heart that
would see Georgia's capital reduced to
ashes their very day the Battle of
rasaka had broken out tomorrow Harrison
would have to join the fighting but not
before he finished one last letter to
his wife the parent married in 1853
socially confident outgoing loved by
everyone she met Caroline Lavinia Scott
was everything the future president
wasn't now Harrison was trying to find
words that might soothe her if he never
came home I'm thinking much of you and
the dear children he wrote I send up to
Gods this night that a you should lose a
husband and they are farther in the
fight that you may find abundant
consolation I know you will not forget
me but let your grief be tempered by the
consolation that I died for my country
just a few hours later as his words were
making this low Way North Colonel
Harrison would lead a semi-suicidal
charge on a Confederate artillery
battery it would be a bloody Affair one
as ferocious as Harrison had feared with
brutal hand-to-hand combat to secure the
guns but in one important respect the
kernel would be wrong that letter
wouldn't be its last Benjamin Harrison
would live to fight another day for a
guy General Sherman would later commend
for his fighting Spirit the story of how
the 23rd president got sucked into the
Civil War is surprisingly dumb while
other future presidents like Rutherford
B Hayes and William McKinley signed up
after Fort Sumter was bombarded Harrison
was essentially guilted and taking part
in summer of 1862 he visited the
governor of Indiana on business only for
the governor to instead go on about how
depressed he was feeling because not
enough locals were signing up to fight
he kept this up until Harrison
volunteered to raise a regiment at which
point the governor was suddenly all like
great I knew I could count on you go and
get him Benny boy initially the plan was
for Harrison to raise the regiment train
the troops and then return to civilian
life oh once they went off to fight but
the further things moved the more guilt
Harrison started to feel here he was
recruiting men with fine speeches
sending them off into a meat grinder
from which many would never return the
least he could do he finally decided was
to go with them and that's how Benjamin
Harrison found himself with a rank of
Colonel leading the 70th Indiana
regiment South to do battle for those of
us tossed with writing about him this
was in many ways the real Pinnacle of
Harrison's life as Commander he seemed
to have an instinct for dealing with
common soldiers acting the hard ass when
he needed to but also doing things like
personally taking coffee to meant
standing guard on cold nights like the
best officers he led from the front but
he also poured over all military books
studying tactics that might give his
regiment an edge and a better chance of
survival and clearly it worked when the
Atlanta Campaign ended the Indiana 70th
was mostly still intact Harrison had
under survived but had been promoted to
Brigadier General he fully in intended
to go on hoping to join Sherman's
Infamous March to the Sea sadly an
attacker scarlet fever laid him low for
a month but by the time he recovered the
Union Army wanted him behind the scenes
training new recruits in South Carolina
he was still there when the war finally
ended for Harris on the Civil War would
always be something he looked back on
with horror as a dirty business where he
did his duty and nothing more yet he
would never forget the men who fought
under him the rank and fall soldiers who
risked so much and when the time came
the future president was going to fight
like hell to reward their bravery
so look here you are in the middle of an
educational video on YouTube I'm going
to make a fairly safe bet that you
rather like learning things and if I'm
right I think you're going to love the
sponsor of today's episode curiosity
stream so look you're here in drawing a
biography on a Channel all about
biographies well if you'd like to get
more in-depth looks at people's lives
that go beyond the 20 to 30 minute
profiles that we do here there are some
great shows and curiosity stream that
you'll love American icons looks at
local people from American history FDR
Babe Ruth Lincoln or hop over the ponds
and there's an hour-long documentary all
about William the Conqueror and these
are just a couple of examples there's
tons of stuff plus you can watch
curiositystream pretty much anywhere
just grab a few minutes on your phone if
you're out and about or put it up on the
big screen TV at home whatever you like
it's also available worldwide so you can
access their full library of content
wherever you are then speaking of
contents you'll never run out as an
addition to thousands of programs
already on the service they're adding
new shows every week so go to curiosity
stream.com slash biographics for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series and
for you guys use the promo code
biographics and you will save 25 which
comes out to only 14.99 a year which
makes it a dollar 25 a month
which is just kind of ridiculous and now
back to today's video
as an officer beloved by his men and
admired by his superiors it's arguable
that a civil war service was the
culmination of Harrison's career at the
moment oh yeah he finally did those
great things that he was destined for
but that's not how the man himself saw
it mustered out on June the 8th 1865
Harrison returned to Indiana while he
initially seemed content to resume his
law practice it wasn't long before a new
ambition began burning in his soul
little Ben I wanted to get into politics
it was a bumpy Journey Harrison tried
running for the Indiana Republican
gubernational nomination in 1872 only to
not even win the blessing of his own
party when he did win the nomination
four years later he then went on to lose
the election for many political wannabes
this could have been the end but not for
Benjamin Harrison not in the fee bra
year of 1876 1876c was the year of the
closest run election in U.S history that
year Democrat Samuel tolton won the
popular vote against Republican
Rutherford B Hayes but neither candidate
gained enough votes to win the electoral
college that's because poor states
returned digital actors we'll go into
the ins and outs when we finally do our
rough of a B Hayes video but the upshot
is that for a handful of months no one
knew who would be the 19th president
Benjamin Harrison Shaw acted like he
knew the outcome as one of Hayes's most
vociferous supporters Harrison made a
name for himself publicly backing the
Republican a move that came to be seen
as genius when Hayes was awarded the
presidency by a single electoral vote
the result was a grateful President
Hayes doing stuff like appointing
Harrison to powerful commissions which
Harrison used to increase his profile in
the party that and Harrison being
allowed to chair Indiana's delegation to
the 1880 Republican convention where he
again showed an uncanny Instinct by
picking the dark horse winner James
Garfield and while Garfield's
assassination will mean his short
presidency was the ultimate Monday for
Harrison everything would be lasagna now
a power player in the GOP Harrison was
soon made senator from Indiana now if
you're confused as to why he didn't have
to run for election well Senators have
only been directly elected since
Woodbridge Wilson's era in the 1880s
they were appointed by the party
controlling the state Ahmed Harrison was
able to sit as Senator so long as the
GOP controlled Indiana and that gave him
a chance to shape his future political
platform looking back it's remarkable
how much of his White House tenure is
reflected in little Ben's Senate career
from 1881 to 1887 he fought tirelessly
for increased benefits for Civil War
veterans conservation of American
Wilderness and the admission of Dakota
as a state this being before anyone
decided to split it into North and South
he then continued his uncanny streak for
picking winners or at least not picking
the losers in 1884 Harrison was
noticeably lukewarm about his party's
nominee James G Blaine although he
didn't follow some colleagues in
switching support to the Democrats he
clearly didn't think Blaine was up to
the job nor did the public Blaine lost
to Grover Cleveland that November the
first Republican to lose a presidential
election since 1854. and now set up
Harrison perfectly for his own shot at
the White House at the 1888 convention
James G Blaine tried to win his party's
nomination for a second time fearing a
repeat of the party split four years
earlier those in charge desperately cast
around for somebody anybody who could
take Blaine's place somebody all
factions could live with they found that
somebody in Benjamin Harrison running as
a rejuvenated Republican Harrison went
toe-to-toe with President Grover
Cleveland that November well we say Toe
to Toe but that sounds much too much
like a fight and while there were some
blows exchanged in the press the 188
campaign was remarkably civil Harrison
ran on supporting a protective tariff to
help American manufacturers Cleveland
ran against it when the results came in
it was clear who had the better offer
although Cleveland had won the popular
vote by 90 000 it lost the key tariff
supporting swing state of New York by a
razor thin margin this combined with
Harrison just carrying his own swing
state of Indiana handed the Republicans
and Electoral College Victory while it
might have been an extremely close race
though Harrison had no intention of
governing like a guy with a tiny mandate
instead he was going to use the G eop's
new Trifecta to force through policies
that would soon upend America
so here we are Benjamin Harrison has
finally become the 23rd president
inaugurated a hundred years after George
Washington first took the job but if
you're now itching to hear what he did
we should make one thing clear
presidents in Harrison's time didn't
really do much of anything today we see
presidents out front shaping the country
and muscling through an ambitious agenda
hence all those dark brand and memes
Reinventing Biden as a do down to kick
ass and chew bubblegum this is thanks to
guys like Tessie Roosevelt and Woodrow
Wilson guys who use the presidency to
take America by the nuts and drag it in
their preferred Direction but in the
post-civil War era that just wasn't how
things were done real power was vested
in Congress while you might get someone
like Grover Cleveland vetoing bills he
didn't like most presidents just kind of
went with a flow so when we spend the
next two chapters of today's video
discussing Harrison's ups and downs it's
important to keep in mind that he's
leading the way on very few of them in
fact it'd be more accurate to think of
his achievements as at best joint
projects undertaken with the 51st
Congress and worst as stuff Congress
simply sent him to sign this is the case
with the really big bills of Harrison's
presidency like the Sherman Antitrust
Act sponsored by Senator John Sherman
the bill was recognition that America
was less the land of the free markets
and more a nation being forced fed
metaphorical manure by Price ranking
cartels passed in 1890 the Act was the
first to authorize trust building a
decade and a bit later Teddy Roosevelt
would famously build on it to smash up
monopolies but while this bill was
important enough to remain on the books
today it's an example of something
Harrison had little influence on besides
him basically going cool idea bro yep
that's not to say Benjamin Harrison ever
pushed forward a project close to his
heart on the issue of conservation the
president was lying as ahead of his era
back in 1881 while serving as Senator
Harrison had visited Yellowstone then
newly Minted as a national park always
an admirer of The Great Outdoors
Harrison had like most Americans been
Enchanted by drawings of this wild and
rugged land now seeing as in person he
seems to have fallen all over again for
the continent's Wilderness back in the
Senate and then in the White House
Harrison pressed hard for more land to
be set aside at a federal level for
commercial activity to be banned in more
areas of Beauty in 1890 he oversaw the
creation of three new national parks
Yosemite Sequoia and Sir now defunct
General Grant Park that would later be
replaced by King's Canyon he also tried
to create a fourth around the Grand
Canyon only for a skeptical Congress to
block him presumably on the grounds that
it was just a big hole in the ground but
while creating some of the USA's
earliest national parks was a big step
Harrison's real achievement came with
forests worried that commercial
companies were tearing down all the
nation's trees little Ben pushed
Congress to sign the 1891 Forest Reserve
Act under its broad Powers Harrison was
able to protect 22 million Acres of
Woodland an area larger than Scotland
now this is yet another law that Teddy
Roosevelt would soon use to a much
greater effect protecting 10 times the
amount of land that Harrison did but the
important point is that Benjamin
Harrison was the Pioneer without his
love of nature there would have been no
law for Teddy to wield in the first
place nor was it just landscape the 23rd
president had a soft spot for during his
term Harrison would challenge Canada and
Great Britain over fursio hunting and
the Bering Sea this was done partially
with economic interests in mind too many
dead seals would wipe out some Alaskan
communities but it was also out of a
concern for an endangered species in
short conservation was perhaps the
biggest area where we can look at
Benjamin Harrison's presidency and say
yeah he actually took the lead on that
but it wouldn't be the only area see the
new president also had some extremely
Progressive views on perhaps the most
explosive issue of the day improving
America's fast deteriorating race
relations
if they gave points for Good Intentions
Benjamin Harrison would sit somewhere
near the top of presidential rankings
thanks entirely to his civil rights work
Venero when American race relations were
not just approaching rock bottom but
already tunneling through the mantle
Harrison was Progressive as hell that
meant appointing ex-slave and leading
intellectual Frederick Douglass as
minister to Haiti it also meant
supporting the federal elections Bill
designed to re-enfranchise Black Folk
living under early Jim Crow it also
meant backing the Blair education Bill
intended to boost literacy rates among
the poorest African Americans to get
around the Deep South literacy tests in
Harrison's era these were not small
steps and he backed them up making
speeches where he accused those saying
well the states handle it of turning a
blind eye to racial violence so given
all that why don't we now remember
little Ben as a great civil rights
President sad answer is because nothing
actually got done while the president
pushed these bills Congress care heard
way more about Arcane stuff like free
silver in fact they get so much that
some Western Republicans cut back room
deals in return for joining them on free
silver they'd let the Democrats
filibuster Harrison civil rights stuff
and that's how the rights prosperity and
even the lives of swalls of black
Southerners came to be sacrificed on the
cross of silver all of which handily
brings us to one of the administration's
biggest squirts the Sherman Silver act
now we're not going to go into it much
here firstly because we've already
touched on it in our Grove at Cleveland
video and secondly because well it's
pretty boring but just know that one of
the major debates of the 1890s was
whether dollars should be backed not
just by gold but also by silver the
Sherman Silver Act made this law
mandating the treasury by heck tons of
shiny metal and allowing people to
exchange their paper money for either
silver or gold it was supposed to make
everyone richer instead it caused a
crash of the price of silver and the
nation's gold reserves were almost wiped
out when people began exchanging their
silverboard dollars for gold this was
such a monumental mess that it's been
partially blamed for the Panic of 1893
the worst oppression on record that not
got the word great attached to it nor
was it the administration's only fiscal
disaster the 51st Congress had a lot of
active members one of whom was future
President William McKinley who authored
something called the McKinley Tariff
coming into force in 1890 it a yanked up
import taxes on 1 500 Goods the idea
being it would protect American
Manufacturing in reality it sent
consumer prices through the floor but
then that was just how the 51st Congress
rolled having come in with a huge budget
surplus the Republicans have proceeded
to spunk it all up the wall becoming the
first Congress in history to appropriate
a billion dollars some of this went on
extremely worthwhile stuff like
expanding benefits to Civil War veterans
a pet project Benjamin Harrison but far
too much of it was perceived to be
wasteful spending and voters were
outraged and that doomed Harrison's
chances of re-election the 1890 midterms
did to the GOP what a well-timed anvil
robbed from a great height does to a
Wiley Coyote the party was smashed
wallet pounded into the dirt while the
Democrats looked on going well me Meep
they lost 93 House Seats still one of
the top three shellackings suffered by a
ruling party in a midterm party star
words like William McKinley were swept
out on a wave of the brightest and the
new 52nd Congress had no intention of
playing ball with the president hence or
why the second half of Harrison's term
is so empty so devoid of major
achievement peppered mostly by losses
like Congress refusing to approve his
plan to Annex Hawaii or refusing to
authorize money to build a canal across
Central America had he managed to win a
second term it's possible Harrison could
have turned this around could have found
other projects to push forward but alas
it wasn't B after just four short years
the American public was going to consign
the 23rd president the Dustbin of
history
in the end the 1892 election was almost
a perfect re-run of 1888 with some
crucial differences having been
nominated as the only man capable of
holding his party together Harrison had
now become the despised front-runner
that everyone wanted to ditch the
problem was there was no clear
alternative James G Blaine was still
around but that would just repeat the
problems of 1884. William McKinley
wanted to run but he was still too young
so in the end the GOP stuck with
Harrison and when the Democrats
re-nominated Grover Cleveland it became
a rematch only this time it would be
tainted by tragedy you may have heard
the phrase October surprise something
that comes out in the last month of a
presidential race like I don't know the
FBI investigating someone's email and it
shakes up the entire contest well 1892
had its own October surprise but rather
than energize either side it instead
sucked all of the wind out of everyone's
sails on October 25th Harrison's wife
died which is two weeks left the
president was plunged into mourning he
barely made any speeches he appeared in
public only twice when he got the news
Grover Cleveland likewise stopped
campaigning out of respect the result
was an unnatural choir as the country
approached polling day and president who
hardly cared whether he won or whether
he lost and that may have been for the
best when the results were announced
Cleveland and like the last time
narrowly won the popular vote unlike
last time though he also swept the swing
states to gain Electoral College Victory
Harrison's response to this defeat he
told friends it was like being freed
from prison the 23rd president left the
White House in March 1893 for a short an
obscure retirement in many ways he was
lucky to get out when he did the Panic
of 1893 would collapse the nation's
economy within months leaving Cleveland
battered by events and so damaging the
Democrats that they wouldn't return to
the White House until 1913. by then
though Benjamin Harrison would be long
dead the 23rd president died on March 13
1901 age 67. he left behind a widow his
second wife Mary dimick a woman 25 years
as junior he left behind two millions of
Acres of preserved Forest plus the six
states admitted under his administration
still the most admitted by a single
president sadly he also left behind a
stench of failure today Benjamin
Harrison is broadly forgotten his
reputation not terrible enough to make
him one of History's hate figures but
also not great enough to make him an
unsung hero in fact you could probably
argue his grandfather William Henry
Harrison Remains the better known
president simply by holding the record
of shortest terms served for all he
dreamed of achieving greatness it seems
that the younger Harrison never even
came close
or did he does this video has hopefully
shown there was much more to Benjamin
Harrison than a simple four-year blank
between Grover Cleveland's two terms
this is a man after all who was a civil
war hero a guy who led men into hell and
cannon fire and lived to tell the Tale
in the white house too he was
far-sighted someone who tried his best
on both conservation and civil rights
even if the reality often fell short of
his ideals to be clear we're not arguing
that Harrison was secretly a great
president there were just too many
misses for that too many transformative
bills that died in the Senate but we are
arguing that perhaps he's been
overlooked that perhaps he was more
forward-thinking and interesting than
he's ever given credit for he may not
have achieved truly great things but to
paraphrase Jack Nicholson and one fell
over the Cookie's Nest God damn it at
least he did
foreign